tenemos aquí la imagen del círculo
unitario cuyo centro es el punto a al
punto b se ubica en el círculo y del
punto b se ha tirado una línea que es
perpendicular con la parte positiva del
eje x para ubicar el punto d para formar
así el triángulo a vd nos dan el ángulo
b ade que mide pi sobre 4 radiales lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
usemos nuestro conocimiento de
trigonometría que usemos nuestro
conocimiento de triángulos para calcular
diversas cosas lo primero que vamos a
calcular es la medida del ángulo vamos a
ponerlo acá la medida
radiantes
del ángulo del ángulo abed del ángulo a
b d de hecho hagamos eso primero y
después calcularemos lo demás así que
supongo que le diste pausa el vídeo que
intentaste hacerlo por tu cuenta
calculemos el ángulo ave de conocemos
dos ángulos del triángulo conocemos
estos dos ángulos del triángulo así es
que podemos calcular el tercer ángulo la
cuestión aquí es que nosotros sabemos
que la suma de los ángulos interiores de
un triángulo es de 180 grados pero aquí
estamos considerando los ángulos en
radiales así es que podríamos decir que
la suma de los ángulos interiores de un
triángulo suman irradian es pues 180
grados equivalen precisamente a pi
radiales así es que este ángulo más este
ángulo más este ángulo van a sumar pi
así es que este ángulo el ángulo a ver
vamos a ponerlo de la siguiente manera
la medida del ángulo
abed más el ángulo que nos dieron el
ángulo de pi cuartos más y cuartos
más este ángulo este ángulo recto que
mide 90 grados 90 grados equivale a pi
sobre dos radiales así es que más y
sobre dos radiales más pi sobre dos esto
tiene que ser igual a 180 grados que es
irradian es así es que esto es igual a
pi despejamos entonces la medida del
ángulo abed para obtener que la medida
del ángulo
abed es igual a pi
menos
y medios - y cuartos hemos restado pi
cuartos y medios a ambos lados y esto es
igual como un denominador es 4 esto es 4
pi sobre 4 esto es 2 pi sobre 42 pi
sobre 4 y esto es menos pi sobre 4
hacemos la resta cuatro primeros dos
primeros pi es cuatro pi cuartos menos
tres cuartos lo cual es igual a cuartos
así es que la medida del ángulo abed es
la misma que el ángulo vea de qué es
sobre cuatro este ángulo aquí mide y
cuartos y de qué nos sirve esto de qué
nos sirve saber que este ángulo espí
cuartos si sabemos que este ángulo mide
peas sobre cuatro y este ángulo también
mide y sobre cuatro radiales pero
también sabemos que este es el círculo
unitario es decir sabemos que el
segmento abc1 es el radio del círculo
unitario qué más podemos conocer de este
triángulo podemos conocer la longitud
del segmento ade y la longitud del
segmento debe claro como tenemos dos
ángulos que tienen la misma medida por
lo tanto los catetos opuestos
los ángulos van a tener la misma
longitud quiere decir que este lado va a
ser congruente con este lado puedo
reorientar este triángulo para que sea
más fácil darnos cuenta de esto si yo lo
voltear a aunque no lo voy a voltear
completamente si hago que el triángulo
se vea así si hago que el triángulo se
vea así a ver déjame hacerlo mejor
déjame hacerlo mejor si hago que el
triángulo se vea si necesito el ángulo
recto vamos a poner claramente este
sería mi ángulo recto
si hago que el triángulo se vea así
visto así este es de este es b y este es
a éste sería el ángulo recto este es y
sobre cuatro radiales y este también es
y sobre cuatro radiales como los dos
ángulos de la base son iguales sabemos
que es un triángulo isósceles no puede
ser un triángulo equilátero pues los
tres ángulos no son iguales si si los
tres ángulos fueran iguales
el triángulo equilátero pero no este es
un triángulo isósceles si los ángulos de
la base son los mismos los lados
opuestos a dichos ángulos van a ser
estos dos lados son iguales y el
triángulo es isósceles y de qué nos
sirve eso para calcular la longitud de
los lados si consideramos que este lado
tiene longitud x entonces este lado
tiene longitud de x si este lado tiene
longitud de x entonces éste tiene
longitud de x entonces si ahora
utilizamos el teorema de pitágoras
tenemos que x cuadrada el cuadrado este
cateto más el cuadrado del otro cateto
más x cuadrada es igual al cuadrado de
la hipotenusa es igual a 1 al cuadrado
sumamos para obtener que 2x cuadrada es
igual a 1 dividiendo entre 2 obtenemos
que x cuadrado es igual a un medio
despejamos x sacando raíz a ambos lados
para obtener finalmente que x es igual a
la raíz de un medio o 1 sobre la raíz de
2 ya mucha gente no le gusta obtener una
expresión donde hay un radical en el
denominador así es que vamos a
racionalizar el denominador para esto
vamos a multiplicar por raíz de dos
sobre raíz de dos y obtenemos en el
numerador que 1 x raíz de 2 es igual a
raíz de 2 y en el denominador raíz de 2
x raíz de 2 que es igual a 2
ya hemos calculado varias cosas
interesantes hemos calculado la medida
del ángulo ave de em radiales hemos
calculado la longitud del segmento a de
y del segmento
dv ahora lo que quiero hacer es que
calculemos seno coseno y tangente de pi
sobre 4 radiales basándonos en el
trabajo que hemos hecho empecemos con el
seno lo voy a hacer en naranja empecemos
con el seno de iu sobre 4 radiales y de
nueva cuenta te invito a que le pongas
pausa el vídeo consideres las
definiciones del círculo unitario y los
cálculos que hemos hecho para obtener tu
respuesta en la definición del círculo
unitario de este ángulo y sobre cuatro
radiales con respecto a la parte
positiva del eje x donde el rayo
terminal intercepta el círculo unitario
las coordenadas de ese punto son lo que
determinan el coseno y el seno del
ángulo así es que las coordenadas de
este punto van a ser coseno de pi
cuartos en la coordenada en equis y la
coordenada en que es
seno de pi cuartos y aquí entonces cuál
es la coordenada en que ese noventa y
cuartos es esta longitud que es el valor
de x por lo cual el seno de pi cuartos
es igual a raíz de dos sobre dos ahora
cuál es el coste no de pi cuartos
nuevamente te invito a que le pongas
pausa el vídeo y local culés por tu
cuenta
cuál es la coordenada en x del punto es
esta longitud que es x que es raíz de 2
sobre 2 con lo cual coseno de cuartos es
igual a raíz de 2 sobre 2 ahora cuál es
la tangente de pi cuartos la tangente ty
cuartos es seno de pi cuartos sobre
coseno de pi cuartos seno epi cuartos
sobrecoste net y cuartos ambos son
iguales esto es raíz de 2 sobre 2
dividido entre raíz de 2 sobre 2 esto es
igual a 1 y eso ese sentido recuerda que
la tangente de este ángulo es la
pendiente de esta recta y vemos que a
medida que avanzamos x unidades
horizontalmente nos elevamos x unidades
es el cambio en james sobre el cambio en
x que en este caso es x sobre x que es
igual a 1